colombian officials are stepping up
assistance to haiti
following the assassination of haitian
president javel muiz
on friday the colombian government
announced that resources and personnel
would be sent to aid in the
investigation
intelligence officials are also sharing
more information about the 26
out of 28 alleged conspirators
identified as colombian citizens
we have the first details about the
travels some of them made
dates from where they went what kind of
airline this is not only shared with
haiti's interpol central office
but with the dominican republic as the
people linked to the incident
used as a port of arrival the dominican
republic to travel to haitian
territory
the unrest on the streets of haiti's
capital has largely subsided
though tensions remain high outside the
u.s embassy in port-au-prince a crowd
gathered
with many saying they seek to flee the
country in anticipation
of a worsening political crisis
we are all here since last night it's a
normal thing to do to try to get out of
the country since our president was
assassinated
the death of president moiz at the hands
of foreign mercenaries left the country
in shock
on friday evening the haitian senate
named joseph lambert as the country's
interim president
former haitian prime minister laurent
lamothe tells al jazeera that
international cooperation in this
investigation is vital
regarding the immediate future of i'm
both concerned
because of course of an assassination of
a president and it's aftermath
but i'm hopeful that the current
government is making the right moves
into inviting international community to
come in
uh opening up the the investigation you
know to the international
partners this way we will ensure a
fair investigative process that would
lead us to
to whoever paid for this in the u.s
the biden administration also pledged to
provide resources
to uncover exactly who killed the
haitian president and why
in response to the haitian government's
request for security and investigative
assistance
we will be sending senior fbi and dhs
officials to port-au-prince
as soon as possible to assess the
situation and how
we may be able to assist
international investigators are also
looking into how such a deadly security
lapse at haiti's presidential palace
could have occurred
the head of the general security unit
for the police guard dmitry iran
now under investigation manuel rapalo al
jazeera